welcome to this video playing 15-minute
game and got default played ok let's see
hasn't decided yet on an opening
let's go for Kings Indian that's always
it often makes form for entertaining
games yeah I know the the big parting of
the ways the classical the most can move
now this law thing doesn't always always
have the slight fear if you do video and
yeah okay he didn't play the exchange
it's not it's not the end of the world
the exchange variation but it is I
played myself as white once in a while
and then it is simply leading to rather
rather dull game and it may mean I'm
quite technical and then everything and
it's got some nice psychological points
as why does the black king senior player
quite often enjoys attacking more than
defending him depending on slightly
sometimes slightly worse end game and
it's very it's very equal ish but still
the big picture key 83-year 83 is quite
quite uncommon this position mmm
interesting is there some way to to
exploit this I wonder about the move a
form made for night takes a for I can
take e for Bishop g5 is probably the the
issue I could play Bishop d7 then cover
the pond and then develop with Queenie 8
and 9 a-6
hmm I don't know or should I prepare
that the safe or idea I cannot let's
play that it sir it's interesting at
least I don't see a a direct problem
the long term it can be helpful to have
them have the queenside blocked so my
development plan would be night a 625 if
possible Bishop d7 covering the f4 pond
and then maybe 98 @ f 5 along along
these lines
yeah Bishop g5 is what usually is a
plate in them yeah the petrossian sister
which this is of course okay let's
protect a form it's written to take f6
and therefore getting the pawn I'm not
so sure about the objective merits of
this a phone booth button it's a it's
it's interesting at least
yeah this is a very direct way to play
okay but is it any good first the other
question um okay let's let's first
tickle this bishop and see where where
it is going I could have at least
considered to take SC 5 now that I think
of it okay but anyway if he takes on f6
this is a serious positional concession
giving me the to the shops and weakening
the dark squares in the process so it
doesn't really I mean Bishop e3 I can I
can even consider an IG form
and if he goes to h4 this Bishop is
potentially offside a bit at least
hmm yeah should i take c phone he goes
to h4 should i take c 5 okay he's going
for them mentioned positional concession
yeah okay I prefer that one one one
reason is after the yeah after this
exchange b6 is an excellent square both
for the Queen and the bishop and now I
have Queen B 6 as a possibility but also
in the long run I might be able to
regroup the Bishop to b6 wire dat da to
be 64 the bishop and yeah this this
really should be excellent for black the
only thing is maybe a short term if you
can do something on the queenside I mean
and it must be short term like in the
next two or three moves with some some
slow moves on black black will be in
excellent shape this is no doubt about
that okay Queen B 6 or is there on some
better move
yeah it's it's it's at least okay so mm
I want I prefer this one not bishop okay
Bishop g7 of course intense f5 which is
not bad at all this Bishop d 8 p-6 ideas
is very nice but it's no okay let's
let's change plans here f5 is really
nice to get in and okay well Bishop to
b6 is a good plan the queen is nicely as
well so um the idea now would be night a
62 c 5 you need to get the night into
play and then then play a five alright
so night a six he intends to probably
take a form take twice 95 mm yeah it's
not though so terribly convincing
so f five but he's got night h4 f5 night
eh fries Battaglia
hmm
ok so let's consider 96-94 Bishop f4
Queenie for Queen B to attacking the e2
bishop and I'm threatening night c 5
which would really call innate
excellently so if he takes rook a6 the
Queen can go to I can go to g7 hmm i'd
look strange
I don't really want to allow that okay
but I don't really see how to get the
pieces out otherwise everything else
looks really like unnatural night Essex
is a six looks like the move to play and
now his his force to take at least on I
think only form Bishop a 6 is like yeah
giving me two bishops against two nights
the Sam of course I'm a very serious
concession of course position is at the
moment rather close but physicians tend
to open up more than to close close up
this is also why bishops are usually
better positions are once opened don't
close up anymore and then the bishop the
rule of course this is a very am general
observation but this is the main reason
why very often bishops are better yeah
okay my thread is 95 and this is such a
big threat he needs to react to that I
think
Oh is there something else yeah I my
main line is night a for Bishop a for
Queen a for Queen B to Bishop a six rook
a six and maybe Queen D sound
hmm
quindi seven there's nothing hanging at
the moment the queen is protecting b7
the rook is protecting this exam yeah
okay cannot play quigley one or
something maybe cream before this could
be a move
27 SM that looks much more much more
natural though and it threatens rupee
one
of course i'd like to get them at the
frog pond but how to do that
hmm complicated
look be one hmm
maybe Ruby 60 just preventing would be
one why not actually the Queen on b2 is
not bad I mean it controls our cancer in
porn squares d 2 maybe i can i can just
play work aah next move and activate the
second look hmm interesting
Brooke b6 and maybe this was strong yeah
okay I can do that but it's not really
helping him so much of course I can you
can maybe a try to win d 6 but I have
fun I cannot take a fall in the process
okay so way to do it or even f5 or is
this suspect
look before to e4 but Kevin once i have
played that he will have rugby one what
about why this needs to be calculated
precisely Bishop f 6 a-5 rook d eight
rooks twin c7 and then move the rook to
before that looks good actually if I
hope the end he can take on d8 bishop
t8a b6 pressure piece Wow Bishop b6 I
can take on f2 I can take what the
bishop right okay then this is a good f5
luke t 8 if it goes queen datsheffy 886
I got Bishop b6 rook a b-1 the shop f to
check king moves Queenie to wendover
okay so 85 rock the eighth he needs to
play Quincy seven and then my rogue d8
protects the six and I can actually move
look before I detect me for I have d6
covered i have b 7 kappa this is nice
and the line i was giving earlier of
Queen d8 check Bishop d8a b6 Bishop p6
okay he just moved away I didn't see
that attacking the hair H sticks okay
it's probably not the end of the board
anyway but i didn't i didn't really see
the move okay rook before i was the idea
anyway I want to attack that's important
e4 pawn and if I win the e4 pawn d5 this
week and I've got d 5 before coming so
he takes them okay if I take it for now
he's got this rook be one idea
and this also yeah yeah that's also not
look B 1 B seven then it's got some been
taking ideas I can also consider the
eight rooks EHC to first
hmm
yeah maybe it is better rook c8 will see
it first attending Roxy too
if he goes h4 rookie for age five I have
hooked reform hmm yeah complicated
uh-huh this I didn't consider at all
and we are interesting why not why not
his son is probably gaining a tempo here
against d6 but it's there some tactical
way to go now somehow I don't know
somehow this looks shaky to me this rock
is loose and maybe I have some ideas
like on the back rank is back rank as a
week Queenie to oak tag sama there is
nothing concrete
you
okay I'm getting down on time
Bishop to g7 and probably I need to I
need this temple
hm
I'm a pawn down Sarah thinks it's all a
bit strange am probably didn't play the
Sun and them and in a very exact fashion
and look at the aid so one possibility
who did
I don't turn don't really see how to how
to answer this satisfactorily twin da
deserves really an ugly move it's got
Luke t7 coming
yeah okay but I'm not two minutes
yeah looked is something I thought maybe
look at four could be could be an idea
intending for now maybe it looks shaky
that looks really shaky
no my TV for at least is active I is
playing this very very precisely it
seems please that's the impression that
it sir that it's conveying
taking the rock
you should f ed can try positive aid
first is why not
Bishop afraid young yeah I'm not sure
some way the some way to trick here
probably nothing better than this
should be mm-hmm
Pusha page to laugh the simple idea if
you move through the night
yeah it's not exactly a great end game
check the biggest problem is the time
well I'm probably lost here it's also an
issue that time check
and yeah but this is this is actually
quite okay check I think either should
be a draw
at least the position I mean time is
another matter
time warning game drawn yeah I think
it's a draw really cannot cannot make
progress their attempts very strange
game I must have lost the way somewhere
in this middle game I mean I cannot
believe that black isn't clearly better
yeah I mean I'm just more active here
with Queen and rook and shouldn't just
be something computer gives it as equal
yeah maybe this was I didn't I didn't
see a sixer this is a problem yeah
probably just take here I didn't want I
didn't want Rock b 1 b 7 like this
variety five ah this is what I didn't
see okay maybe here I looking for wow I
didn't see that of course about what the
moment maybe she was I didn't see that
I'm actually attacking d5 I thought he
would go here and then I don't know
that's some ideas here but I can just
take you and my man betim okay but my
problem was I I didn't see a six at all
and TI probably is tricky yeah look at
four has given us better by the computer
and T I'm in trouble
Bishop f6 okay yeah Bishop f6 probably
gets the porn back but didn't didn't
really have much time yeah this this
actually gives gifts black some some
chances to draw check yeah i'm not sure
if why should win this it's it's
definitely not not totally easy didn't
have any chatty time on the clock check
this is a draw yeah the comp is actually
on 0000 so what is really a check I
still think it's the drone yeah that
cannot win this no way alright
interesting game thanks for watching